ils ont vu tous les pirates des caraïbes
ce sont des youtube heures il adore les
trésors et l'argent et aujourd'hui ils
vont former un équipage de luxe mais son
quota car il est pas la bienvenue l'unc
terre acide cyril et mika aujourd'hui on
va aborder les gens on va débuter et on
va voler leur trésorerie et [ __ ] mais
je arrêter se laisser guider
non mais j'en moi j'en peux plus des
amis il ya deux manières de gagner
soit on bourrine de boules et le bateau
et demi et ma coulé on a gagné soit on
le grap et enfin un abordage et on les
tue tous et on a gagné
du coup les amis je propose d'y aller je
monte à la barre j'ai le barreau car ce
jeu à l'air bien les gars on va à la
vitesse maximale j'ai juste et me faire
en sorte qu'on soit pas une île chargé
le canon de devant et du côté droit à
pourquoi t'es mort mais j'ai glissé sur
la vigie mais [ __ ] cyril est mort
lequel égard le bateau est en face
attention est ce que vous êtes prêts à
tirer que les deux canons de danse ou de
qui plus est ce qu'on a à distance au
stand instants de sa tante va c'est raté
à peu à droite a pas droit tu as plein
droit de vazyvaza des mourides est oui
si on les a touchés continue comme ça au
large d'angra paix avec les cadres de
droite je dirais bien terrasser bon grip
et c'est partie des gammes à l'abattage
au je me suis dit one shot je suis mort
terra tous vos pauses sur toi tu es le
second capitaine personnes pensera le
chercher ici et là tu là mais bon on va
rien dire tu étais derrière un mur dont
elle pouvait pas toucher mais ce parc
c'est un très bon jeu acheté les amis
c'est une défaite je ne vais pas vous
mentir je suis très déçue même par mois
capitaine ouais j'aimerais que tout le
monde y mette un peu plus du sien et que
mes ordres soit exécutée mais moi oui
ferme ta gueule les amis oubliez pas des
canons devant des grappins à droite
ok ok
mais [ __ ] mais sert il ya des flaques
d'eau partout vous êtes vraiment le pire
équipages de ma carrière j'ai jamais eu
d'aidés telle grandeur sur un bateau
mais bon droit et la droite des carreaux
des deux ans prévus
on les profs nature vous n'êtes plus là
je vais tourner à droite préparer les
deux ballons devant on va leur mettre
des boulets dans le cul égale ok ok
après c'est flanc droit où flanc gauche
flanc au chocolat c'est pas drôle projet
de film black comme ça je le jette à
l'eau s'est retirée
oui c'est beau aller continu continu
recharger canon on est derrière solution
pas dit à l'étude alors ok les gars je
descends descends bleus il ya des mecs
dans la cale en fasse attention aux
[ __ ] michael moore tout le monde est
en train de mourir
les amis vous à les charger les canons
du côté gauche je répète du côté gauche
du bateau j'ai mis les voiles attendait
d'en tirer attendait mungo basque ils
vont aussi vite que nous ces groupes
brigands attends je vais partir un petit
peu exprès de manière à ce que ouais
c'est vrai oh allez les gars on les paye
on les baisse ils savent plus quoi faire
ok chargé qui en devant on va l'armée
déroulée dans le calme devant son refus
ils sont chargés
ok attention prévient vont attirer 3 non
au voile à ok à gauche est ce que vous
êtes prêts à gauche attirer bientôt eba
d oui ok les gars d'importants membres
d'abandon abordons la bande à l'essai à
l'aider à les y expose elle a exposé le
bateau tous les cas mais là on n'est pas
en train de couler ça c'est une illusion
d'optique t'en fais pas on n'est pas en
train de couler thermale à toi voilà je
lui préparais réparer le bateau au
départ et le bateau moussaillons ça je
me sens vraiment fort bon je sais pas ce
que tu es en train de faire mais bon ok
mais tu étais grappin sur la gauche sur
la gauche des grappins sur la gauche
c'est bon groupe pour chercher au quai à
cause des prix a grimpé presse papier
ces grappes et les a mis là ça va se
passer au chinois
ils m'ont tué pendant que je conduisais
et je suis prêt à grimper devant
capitaine ça y est c'est trop tard c'est
trop tard c'est a plus aucune utilité
hé les gars baiser les pc les pc et les
baisers les eaux kg intérieur un
deuxième fait son choix il va tu me
tiens au whisky les skiffs du tendon oui
allez au dernier relais birmingham et
carmelo faut combien des coûts c'est bon
on sait qu'il a bon les amis je suis
fier de vous je suis fier de nos
manoeuvres
je suis fier de notre style bravo à tous
les amis postuler tous en tant que
capitaine et on va élire un nouveau
capitaine
je promets du thé à foison ouais
le soir il y aura de la gnôle et des
femmes à les joindre pour cyril je donne
cent mille euros youtuber ok on va tous
pour mika et voit la mecanica capitaine
sylvain ce qu'il a jamais joué au jeu
donc on va avancer reculer
ok les canons les canons à droite sont
prêts je répète les canaux à droite sont
prêts faut pas tout tout droit au qatar
je vais tirer attention au feu sa douche
ça bouge et j'ai vu un mec avec le
boulet au je mettrai mon café côté droit
je suis prêt je suis prêt je suis prêt
ok je vois arriver je ne vois arriver
éloigne-toi l'autre doivent un peu plus
vers la gauche
on va faire une retournée acrobatique
avec un bateau ça arrive ça et je repars
et vous est-ce que vous êtes prêts aux
ménages et il est trop tôt [ __ ] mais
on a un capital de toury la [ __ ] on
appris hier
comment engager moi j'ai pu pas faire je
bois se laisse pas faire rivasi je pense
que je peux mieux vaut mais voit pas le
thé bordel dans une situation pareille
j'ai besoin de monter sur les bases et
le brésil avaient scellé le cas dans les
cas dont les canons remplissait les cas
donc je peux demande de [ __ ] ok ok ok
vas-y bouge plus faut hausser pouces est
beau mais [ __ ] ce qu'on est en train
de remettre ou continue de charger bon
gars attention phare et bien je vais
rater -40 côté droit côté droit armé
côté droit mais attends mais tu fais toi
60 avec le matou quoi ça change tout le
temps
attends ça fait un peu trop à gauche ok
go être rechargé vite chargé des grapo
on peut les aborder mais telegraph un
côté droit ça tapait de quel côté
hôpital ya un trou au [ __ ] ya deux
trophées sont réparés par me paraît pas
en temps réel on s'emballe et sec
retourne à ma gauche - dont je m'écarte
ou à gauche un peu à droite un peu à
droite un peu à droite je tourne au
ralenti ma droite âgé prébendes et
l'enfer en bas ah ouais les mecs c'est
vraiment l'enfer on n'en peut plus qu à
l'épaule droite mais tient à tourner à
droite ça mais je tourne tourne presque
pas tout de combattant des droits
tout me tourne aussi ok les gars
attention je vais tenter un drap
attention attention attention
est-ce que je vais changer le cours de
l'histoire ces grappes et non j'ai
grimpé l'eau nickel et vendent bien ce
jeu capitaine ste claire amestoy on va
être à cours de bull et on va être à
court de tous les chiens dans le vide
lesquels gens font de ce jugement mais
non non non j'ai grimpé les gars on a
tous envie avec l'inde
on a foutu le feu auquel les a mais on y
va on y va il ondemand région de mort
samedi dans l'ue cafouille allez je sais
il sortira pas bon je sais faire poster
fait râler faut sauter faut y aller
michael soit y allez on y va on y vend
des carnivores je le vois kw avec sa
calvitie
c'est mon jeu les tuer le deuxième lot
des âmes oui je suis fier de vous vive
la france
on a vraiment tout donné dans cette game
et ça c'était beau il y avait de
l'émotion il y avait des moments épiques
il y avait de l'amitié aussi parfois
c'était génial vas-y voté pour pommes de
terre au moins je trouve que comme
slogan pour une campagne pommes de terre
sainte
ok et herat on est en attente et or je
répète on attend que tes ordres
ok ok en bas tout est chargé on est prêt
à faire feu bon ok on est prêt attention
au jeu tu as un mec canon droite on est
prêts on est prêts on est prêts on est
prêts on est prêts on est prêt en train
de finaliser
on les a pas grimper nous encore c'est
sa tombe et les grappes et des grains
fait ces grappes est ok les gars on
arrive on arrive on y va on y va
au bar ou dans le calme mais j'ai raté
j'ai raté j'ai bien hâte et j'ai raté
aux ébats fait peur il m'a surpris dans
la cale en bas de l'autre côté terra
licorne derrière des caisses et tu sais
pas je suis peut-être pas non
les amis j'aimerais nommer un capitaine
l'unc l'arc tu va nous guider vers la
victoire
voilà l'un capitaine il était capitaine
voilà c'est une chanson ok on part sur
une manoeuvre préparer le flanc gauche
flanc gauche manque de préparation à
gauche mais couenne et gras pain ou des
boulettes mais un grappin l'avant et que
des poulets ensuite hockey non seulement
il vaut mieux attendre
attention atteint cet âge décent m'a dit
tu verras tu iras tu iras tu retires et
metella total était un attentat jo
j'en ai eu trois jamais il ne reste plus
qu'un elle est légale et c'est légal et
pis c'est tout olalala à cette rangée on
a traversé leurs entrailles et on a bu
leur sang les amis c'est avec une très
grande fierté que je vous annonce que je
pars à la retraite vous en maths et les
couilles mais c'est bien ça fait plaisir
et voilà les amis si avant de céder on
n'était pas là mais ça vous a plu merci
et merci à l'inquiéter incident merci
mika de d'avoir accepté de faire partie
de mon équipage
vous avez le pire capitaine de la
planète mais ses parades franchement
c'était super chouette
vous m'avez deux de très bons conseils
et franchement le jeu est hyper m'a
envoyé à quelques bugs mais c'est quand
même très très drôle
est ce qu'on peut dire qu'on a tous
sortir une vidéo de ceux ici-présents
fouet oui on adore l'originalité ici et
vous souhaiter de plus cette vidéo
n'hésitez pas à aller voir la chaîne de
télé jean cau participent à cette vidéo
bien sûr description portez vous bien
sûr tout le monde
[ __ ]
et surtout n'oubliez pas ou en qu'il
studio c'est mieux que squeeze à bientôt
[Musique]
ça